a busy day for ban ki-moon  secretary-general of the United Nations  on a whistle-stop tour of the European  institutions in Brussels the aim of his  visit explaining his vision on migration  while we need to see more effective law  enforcement actions against the  traffickers we also need safe  alternatives too dangerous voyages as  well as illegal channels such as  resettlement family reunification and  work and study visas ban ki-moon also  announced that he will present an action  plan against violent extremism later  this year we must always be mindful of  our special responsibility to avoid  responses to terrorism and violent  extremism then make the problem worse  globe thus ziana directly cloud rodigan  fair play today ed and a feed fasting  and Sue's ahmedabad a la verga of these  planets in as a next step the UN will  possibly vote for resolution on an  operation against smugglers in the  Mediterranean